looks like we're officially here guys
all right so let me take where we're at
we're on our way to Dallas Texas and we
see Cisco Texas and so we exit let me
tell you what's so special about Cisco
Texas right we're on the startup
entrepreneurs or Cisco Texas is known
for two things one it's known for the
largest concrete swimming pool in the
world and the other thing it's known for
is this building here we did what's so
special and significant about this
building here right looking at a road or
not so you can see it so this right here
see that right there it says Mobley
hotel you know what's so significant
about this building here that was the
first hotel
Conrad Hilton ever bought back in 1920s
so legend has it he was driving through
here he couldn't find a hotel room but
he said he decided to buy this building
he's on his way to buy a bank after he
bought this building this hotel it was
so profitable for him because you would
think why would anybody have a
profitable hotel in Cisco Texas well
because oil was booming here and the oil
field workers used to stay here
it was always full and 8090 years later
from that small little building bad
thing about nobody imagined if you're
the first employee working at that place
maybe get a stock of it you got a piece
of it no one's even thinking anything
about it now Hilton's in 78 different
countries six continents over three
hundred thousand employees and all got
started right there and that is now the
Chamber of Commerce building
headquarters for Cisco Texas
sometimes big things happen in cities
and places that no one is thinking about
or painting that any attention to so the
next time the question comes up what
could you say that Cisco Texas largest
concrete swimming pool in the world and
where the first Hilton was bought and
the legend of Hilton Hotel were started
where in Iran I remember my father would
take us to a nice restaurant on top of
Hilton and Hilton was the prime spot in
Iran where the wealthy people would go
to dine this is it pretty amazing huh
talk about the startup and entrepreneur